hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute das beschissenes spiel der welt
das hier ist der trailer zum you later
der titel verspricht tatsächlich mehr
als das spiel beinhaltet hier klicken
einfach auf play teile zum later und
sitzen auf toilette kam das gerade auf
toilette katze aber hauptsache es kommt
nichts
und zwar um etwa eine halbe atombombe du
und haben die sonst oft samples der ganz
normale ok und die haben noch und
press escape to flash okay ich kann
theoretisch da wir haben es durch
gespielt als ob wir nicht mehr machen
können aussah und dann und und und dass
die die immer die die die dd dd
ich möchte nur einen ganz leisen kurz
nicht so wie ich höre auf wenn ich jetzt
flasche dann habe ich das spiel
durchgespielt wenn ich jetzt noch play
time ziemlich hätte vorher clique
ich gebe da das einfach gerade viel zu
kurz habe ich mir gedacht ich spiele
noch einen zweiten tolle zum leiter der
wiege mich so aus ist auf jeden fall
schon mal wieso sieht man eine maus noch
ich glaube ich bin das klopapier ich
kann wieder mit der maus aus dem
bildschirm raus das ist ja das hatten
wir schon mal so wenn man echt kurzform
augen trägt wenn man das so sieht
ich kann hier oben aufm oder klicken
dann haben wir dann kann ich auf dem
motorrad dann habe ich die jungs die
sonne leuchten
ich kann auch neid mord klicken dann
haben wir nachts was macht das für einen
sind jetzt gehen wir draußen eine
großstadt
und wenn ich auch weltkrieg den wir
draußen berge
kann ich mich bewegen kann ich irgendwie
scrollen
ich habe jede taste einmal gemütlich
tatsächlich nichts machen außer dieses
klopapier anschauen die einen zur sache
nicht mache dann ist das ganze zu einer
spitz atmosphäre macht um dann wieder
zum demo dann wieder zu - mode und dann
sehe ich da gerade licht animationen und
dann wieder zum download an alle spiele
entwickler nie nein und den kleinen
jungen hier zum weinen bringen vom
computer was ist das für eine scheiße
also ich es ja wirklich ein scheiß
baldigen ich bin einfach mal ruhig noch
sind solch gefallen hat dann kann ich
sagen es hat euch nicht gefallen freunde
es tut mir leid aber weder selbst hier
wenn ihr coolere spieler habt die witzig
denn die müssen nicht an großen sinn
haben müssen nur ihnen was können
ich glaube ich bin gerade meine
büroklammer gefahren eine panik gewarnt
die büroklammer sondern nur meine
kopfhörer
die sind jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
kaputt denn irgendwelche coolen spiele
kennt dann schreibt in die kommentare
ja was müsst ihr sonst noch so machen
den daumen hoch müsste definitiv geben